the august jobs report was way off
expectations employers added just 235
000 jobs last month that's about three
times lower than predicted
christina rafini is at the white house
where president biden addressed the jobs
report before visiting the storm damage
in louisiana christina good morning
good morning jeff you know like you said
the economy did add jobs and that's a
good thing the problem is the economy is
still nowhere near as healthy as it was
before covid and the fear is too slow a
recovery could compromise the recovery
altogether
what we're seeing is an economic
recovery that's durable and strong
taking the glass half full approach to
last month's jobs report president biden
tried to redirect focus on the total
number of jobs created since coming to
office
it's not just that i've added more jobs
in in the first year of any president
it's that we've added jobs in every
single one of my first seven job reports
but that progress has stalled as the
highly contagious delta variant spreads
both covid and economic uncertainty we
saw that every month was a new drama it
was a new crisis it was one step four
two steps back and it looks like this is
a perfect example of that the delta
variant while unemployment ticked down
the average number of covid cases hit
six figures prompting americans to scale
back both hiring and spending for three
months i didn't have any income
making matters worse those pandemic
federal unemployment benefits are about
to expire for more than seven million
americans
my partner and i sat down and we figured
it out and we said okay this is the
minimum that we need to pay our bills
now president biden said he believed the
economy would improve if congress would
pass his multi-billion dollar spending
plan but west virginia senator joe
manchin the democratic swing vote says
he's not sold on the price tag dana all
right christina thank you